per questi ragazzi e poi perché questo
video sono fa vj prima di cominciare la
volevo farvi allora c'è una domanda alla
quale volevo rispondere in partenza nel
video poi parte del blog ma prima lo
rispondere a questa sì come ragazzi
nello scorso blog successo che volevo
far vedere che cosa c'era lo sgabuzzino
ha praticamente anche la gente tra
strada mi ha chiesto che cazzo c'è nello
sgabuzzino cemente tutti mi avete
chiesto e quindi volevo far partire
video con questa la prima domanda di
oggi che cosa c'è nello sgabuzzino
vi lascio al video ci siamo ragazzi la
madonna ubriachi braucci fino ci sono
delle cose tipo cos'è questo o mio dio
che c'è uno scatto che cazzo c'è di qua
ma che figo
no io io io io non ho fatto io non ho
fatto un cazzo
giuro che non ho fatto un cazzo donna
cos'è quello che cazzo è questo se ci
sono delle immagini di gente fatta in
questo sgabuzzino poi che abbassa fatto
di salvatico prima di uscire ci sappiamo
tipo la bottiglia di queste
[Musica]
so che vi ho rotto il cazzo con casey
coming soon ma mi piace bello a tutti
ragazzi ebbene questo video sono fa vj e
non ci siamo in un nuovo prima di
cominciare vuole impartire con la farà
della settimana che allora voi avete
visto fino ad oggi da da due anni faccio
blog più o meno avete visto sempre fan
art disegno ovviamente cose del genere
lafon art di oggi è un disegno solo chi
elio non ho idea di come sia possibile
non lo so questa persona mi ha disegnato
partendo da un joystick da un gesti non
so come sia possibile questo concetto
non ci fosse con come come come come
cazzo è così come ha fatto ad insegnarvi
da un cazzo di gioco non ci posso
credere o in realtà era un joystick da
pic che gli sono nato joystick e sono
diventato così verso i 14 anni noi tutti
tutti gli esseri umani nascono joystick
poi poi diventano perso dopo però mi
hanno mentito
dopo aver visto l'opera d'arte del 2015
dire che possiamo passare al modello
prima news ragazzi voglio assolutamente
ringraziarvi di cuore perché da ieri
siamo arrivati ad un milione conto che
siamo un milione e seicentomila non mi
ricordo manco io un milione 600 mila
siti ragazzi veramente grato ogni volta
e dico grazie dovete bastonarmi perché
lo avrò detto un miliardo però non mi
stanco mai la seconda news
un traguardo che ho raggiunto diciamo io
libro che stavo scrivendo che mi aveva
chiesto di farlo la mondadori è stato
accettato e non ci potrò c'è allora ho
scritto questo libro raccontando più o
meno ciò che è successo da quando sono
dove hanno iniziato a farlo youtuber
diciamo che un traguardo incredibile per
me anche per il fatto che io comunque ho
sempre amato scrivere perché poi un
libro mi viene pubblicato sicuramente
anche perché ho tanto seguito questo
penso che sia ovvio perché le ovviamente
a mondadori diventi liberò veramente il
fatto che comunque io sia riuscita non
si perché vi sareste iscritto delle
cagate ovviamente magari aveva detto ma
anche no io non sono una persona che si
definisce chissà che genio però sono
veramente contento che sia piaciuto a
chi l'ha letto pre prova e quindi
veramente non vedo l'ora di sapere che
cosa ne pensate voi del libro io sono
veramente contentissimo già così la
mente contento che volevo condividere
questa cosa con voi una figata pazzesca
cresce il mese prossimo che sono amici
quando è libero
guaita fucking se con qualche bello il
momento dell'arrivo allo scarto dei
pacchi che non ho i pacchi che brutta
frase che cosa ho deciso di fare questa
volta al posto dello scat aggio dei
pacchi rimetterci come sto facendo
questo film si stanno preparando a
livello distante quindi di ci stanno
segnando un fortino le basi del kung fu
io che non ho mai fatto un cazzo va
veramente un cazzo di niente e mi sono
fatto filmare dopo 23 giorni per vedere
più o meno come cazzo ero messo io io
non ti vergogni a farvi vedere queste
cose però devo farmi lascio al video a
voi a voi i commenti
[Musica]
come ci si sente ad essere un
combattente si sa suonare anche le
percussioni fa vj perfetto questo era io
passo le giornate così cucchiai anzi
questo è quello che ho fatto per le
nell'ultima settimana mi hanno insegnato
ad alzarmi da terra da sdraiato nel
disco vi faccio vedere che il gatto ha
deciso di fare è morta perché sono un po
ppd ragazzi questo è quello che ho
imparato fino adesso cioè è una roba
deve adesso io siccome sono diventato un
esperto ninja farò dei tutorial su come
fare certe cose diventeremo un eserciti
lei fosse dal fare risponde prima di
scendere del trash ancora di più da
prima domanda arriva da melbourne ha già
visto amanda è bellissima affari sfondo
il preservativo gonfiano e usano come se
fosse un palloncino e divertente
seriamente non posso cambiare questi
temi perché ragazzi di the spiegatemelo
vi prego si gonfia e così si fa il sesso
ma c'è un pezzo di preservativo sul
money la macchia schifo poi risponde
fuori ci mostri 50 sfumature di te è
arrivato ai fumatori di te molto
semplice la partiamo dal classico tè
classico poi abbiamo river de la
vaniglia vietato se sembra sembra ganja
però vi assicuro che te no forse forse
gangio era una battuta pessimo e quindi
ragazzi la fabi domanda di oggi
stava morendo questa cosa qui è
veramente ganja perché c'è scritto
vaniglia ma è un nome per sviare le idee
di ragazzi se il video è piaciuto come
solito sotto commento mi piace anche a
faccia di facebook e come nei video
trovata una descrizione sei un signore
si desti 20 nocivi e uno dei ragazzi e
voglio fottutamente sapere che cazzo ne
pensate all'inizio del video devo
saperlo io son convinto che da oggi in
avanti non tormenti nessuno però vabbè
[Musica]